all right we got some superhero movie
news for you guys the first one is for
Zack Snyder's Superman Man of Steel and
it turns out even though Zack Snyder
denied it to his death General Zod is
the bad guy in Superman the Man of Steel
and they got Michael Shannon from
Boardwalk Empire to play man if you've
seen him in Boardwalk Empire you know he
has that whole like big creepy menacing
guy thing down he talks like he's really
yeah and if you just look how his face
looks and the tone of his voice he does
look and sound like Terence Stamp Zod
but it really doesn't know me when they
cast people because they look and sound
like someone else when it's not an
actual sequel I mean I personally
thought Gerard Butler would have been
perfect his odd you imagine that no
people would just it would have been
less like the Terence Stamp Zod but I
would have thought it was awesome from
what I know if this new guy it feels
like he's gonna be just like the Terence
Stamp sign which is an iconic villain
but don't be afraid to take it your own
direction man seriously
it's called being an artist then again
he might sound nothing like he sounds in
Boardwalk Empire I don't know he might
do a whole new take on Zod maybe it'll
be like the Zod musical and now we have
news for The Dark Knight Rises yes
Joseph gordon-levitt in the movie as
Alberto Falcone which I think will be
perfect because I read the long
Halloween it's awesome that's not why
I'm here I'm here to talk about Josh
pence being cast in the movie and if you
haven't seen Batman Begins yet you turn
this off I guess is will ruin a couple
things Josh pence is going to be young
Rachele Ghul a Ra's al Ghul however you
want to say it effort both animated
series he was Rachele cool movie he was
Ra's al Ghul I'll say both just for the
sake of being you know fun who is this
guy well he's the other Winkle vine
yeah from social network they filmed two
dudes and he took one guy's face and put
it on the other one so Winklevoss body
number two is gonna be Rachelle Ghul I
really doubt they're gonna do the
Lazarus Pit thing so I imagine it's
gonna be flashbacks which also you think
why would they bring up flashbacks if
they're not gonna touch on his family
and Marion cottilard is in the movie no
one knows who she is at this point
because we have young Ra's al Ghul I'm
pretty sure it's gonna be his daughter
Talia al Ghul Anne Hathaway
yeah Christian Bale dude's got the life
and before you touch on the Katie Holmes
thing there is a rumor out there that
Katie Holmes is gonna be in The Dark
Knight Rises as Elaine Dawes Rachel das
a sister that would be all sorts of
weird I've looked over the Internet the
only thing I can find it validate it is
IMDB has her listed and then there's
like just a bunch of blogs of people
talking about it nothing other than that
Warner Brothers hasn't said anything no
one else has said anything at one point
IMDB had like Thomas Haden Church
playing venomous bye
which means I gotta call on
that but until we get more validation
I'm just saying it's a rumour right now
and please don't tell me you
guys are gonna be like I'm actually this
website has it too cuz I'll just break
my heart but if you have it post it
below so we got General Zod one of the
biggest most iconic badasses in the new
Superman movie and we have Batman's
nemesis and trainer from the first movie
in flashbacks what do you think about
all this news comment below let me know
and of course as always if you like what
you've seen here and you want to see
more click right here to see more
[Music]